Macau is an 11 square mile Enclave on
the southern coast of mainland China for
over four centuries it was under
Portuguese rule and today it's the
closest place to China where gambling is
legal in 1962 chinese businessman
stanley ho was the first to usher in a
new era of casinos in Macau for decades
ho built a gambling empire that raked in
billions he paved the way for other
investors to make it big in Macau today
one of those investors is Stanley hos
son Laurence ho my father revolutionized
the you know kind of the casino market
40 years ago in Macau and he brought in
kind of a new style
throughout my career and also you know
throughout my life it's been about
trying to prove myself right it was
important to you to prove that you could
build a company from scratch
yes determined to break out of his
father's shadow
Lawrence partnered up with Australian
James Packer himself the son of a famous
tycoon and together they formed Mel Co
crown their properties include too
extravagant resorts whose opulence gives
Las Vegas landmarks a run for their
money
city of dreams is the ultimate
destination for bourbon entertainment in
Macau
laurens refers to the city of dreams as
an integrated resort where tourists come
to not only put their chips on the table
but spend at high-end boutiques and stay
at 5-star hotels what has Las Vegas
inspired in you or what have you no the
casino moguls their how they should have
helped you along in you know in terms of
inspiration in Macau well you know I
think many times in Asia a lot of people
they built slowly and more conservative
whereas you know when you go to Las
Vegas and you see the mega Resorts the
three thousand five thousand rooms you
know with the shows the theaters the
nightclub my philosophy is more along
those lines like go big or go home
bigger better and wetter part of
Lawrence's vision is attracting
customers through live performances
including this acrobatic experience
called house of dancing water while
Lawrence is bringing lots of glitz and
glam gambling in Macau Sheldon Adelson
says he invented the concept in Vegas
first and now he says he's the one who
will conquer Macau they vastly predicted
and wrongly predicted that I won't even
open I'd never get a belt and if I got a
belt I won't open and if I open I'd be
bankruptcy immediately they didn't want
to believe that somebody else could do
under the connected right
they grossly underestimated me Edison
didn't just succeed he dominated his
first resort The Sands Macau was so
successful he made back the initial 265
million dollar investment in just the
first year thirty thousand people showed
up more than thirty thousand we don't
know the exact number because as they
waited to get in they knocked the doors
down Adelson went on to build the
massive 6,400 room Sam's coat eye
central and a 2,900 room Venetian Macao
as many of Adelson's peers have noted
it's his very success in Macau that is
unwittingly left Vegas in the dust a
point not lost on the billionaire did
you ever think that Macau was going to
surpass Las Vegas in the way it has yes
what convinced you well when we first
applied in Macau in 2002 there was two
and a half billion in gross gaming
income by oh four when we opened the
sands five and a half billion five and a
half billion right in two years Wow the
business was already there I I think
that people weren't recognizing it how
do I think it was going to grow because
there was 1.3 billion Chinese